queridos amigos amigas en las dictaduras
a pesar de que todo suele parecer
estable bajo el yugo amenazador del
poder absoluto y la represión policial
frecuentemente las cosas no paran de
moverse entre bambalinas al fin y al
cabo esa puede ser la única forma de
sobrevivir o sobresalir Pues bien
Venezuela no es una excepción no lo ha
sido no lo es y mientras dure el régimen
bolivariano no lo será de esta forma el
pasado 20 de marzo tare que laissami el
otro era poderoso ministro del petróleo
y presunto narcotraficante según el
gobierno de Estados Unidos presentó su
renuncia en medio de algunas
investigaciones sobre corrupción Sí sí
por mucho que te cueste creerlo Este es
el contexto como si la corrupción no
formará parte de la identidad de la
mismísima Revolución bolivariana lo que
hay que ver El caso es que hablamos de
una trama en torno al oro negro caribeño
que ya ha provocado múltiples
detenciones hablamos por supuesto
de toda una enorme purga interna en las
entrañas del último resquicio del
socialismo del siglo XXI Pero qué
demonios está pasando dentro del
chavismo quienes ganan y quiénes pierden
con toda esta historia está la
Revolución bolivariana crujiendo por
dentro Pues bien Vamos a averiguarlo
arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
Venezuela es un país que sobre todo
tendría que hacernos pensar en petróleo
este país asienta sobre una reservas
probadas de más de 300.000 millones de
barriles de crudo para que os hagáis una
idea esto representa casi el total de la
reserva de dos países como Irak e Irán
juntos
Hablamos de una inmensa riqueza natural
que ha sido administrada por el estado
desde
1975 ese año se decretó la
nacionalización de la industria
petrolera bajo la gestión de la compañía
petróleos de Venezuela sociedad anónima
pedevesa una empresa que rápidamente se
convirtió en la gallina de los huevos de
oro
según datos del Banco Mundial las rentas
petroleras han representado
históricamente cerca del 20% del pib
venezolano y Eso sin contar la suma de
toda la cadena de valor del sector esto
es la comercialización el transporte o
el procesamiento de los derivados es
decir que la relevancia Real del Oro
negro en la economía venezolana ha sido
en las últimas décadas muy superior Pues
bien Ahora cerca de 50 funcionarios y
empresarios relativamente relevantes
están en prisión por una aparente
investigación que el gobierno de Nicolás
maduro ha impulsado por sospechas de
corrupción en la superintendencia de
criptoactivos y la vicepresidencia de
comercio y suministros de pedevesa en
base a este caso importante referente
chavistas están siendo acusados de
apropiación del patrimonio público y
hasta de traición a la patria
siempre ha sido la caja de Pandora de la
historia reciente de Venezuela ahora que
uno de los casos más complejos para el
orden interno del chavismo estalle
dentro de esa entidad no puede parecer
una sorpresa o quizás sí atentos
[Música]
burocracia rotativa una costumbre en el
chavismo
[Música]
estoy seguro de que todos lo sabemos no
es un secreto el socialismo bolivariano
fue un proyecto personalísimo encarnado
en una figura fundamental Hugo Chávez
frías de hecho durante años el eslogan
del partido socialista Unido de
Venezuela fue somos millones una sola
voz sí la voz del comandante
ya no soy yo
Chávez es un pueblo
Chávez somos millones
Tú también eres Chávez mujer venezolana
Tú también eres Chávez joven venezolano
Tú también eres Chávez niño venezolano
Tú también eres Chávez soldado
venezolano tú también
pescador agricultor campesino
comerciante Jorge Chávez no soy yo
es un pueblo de esta forma Aunque la
cara visible de todo el proceso de toda
la revolución fue siempre Hugo Chávez su
gabinete fue siempre muy volátil
Hablamos de una rotación de ministerios
y funcionarios inédita no solo en la
historia del gobierno venezolano sino
prácticamente en las de cualquier
sistema presidencialista Aunque mejor no
lo comparemos con el expresidente del
Perú Pedro Castillo ya sabéis todos se
puede superar siempre El caso es que los
gobiernos de Chávez fueron terriblemente
movidos fijaos en esta tabla si nos
fijamos en ministerios clave como el de
producción o salud veremos que a duras
penas los ministros duraban más de dos
años en el cargo y ojo porque ocurría
exactamente lo mismo en lo que respecta
a la vicepresidencia un cargo que en
Venezuela es designado por el propio
presidente fijaos 8 vicepresidentes en
poco más de 13 años no me digáis que la
cosa no estuvo movida la media por cada
uno fue de 19 meses en cierta forma
cualquier alto cargo revolucionario era
prescindible excepto por supuesto el
propio Hugo Chávez aunque también había
algo más que era sagrado me estoy
refiriendo Claro está a la gallina de
los huevos de oro negro atentos
el Ministerio del petróleo y la minería
solo sufrió tres cambios durante todo el
gobierno de Hugo Chávez Aunque en
realidad tras el paro petrolero que
sufrió el país entre 2002 y 2003 como
consecuencia de la resistencia de los
trabajadores de pedevesa a las políticas
chavistas el titular de la entidad ya no
volvió a cambiar Rafael Ramírez fue el
conductor de la industria petrolera
venezolana durante todo ese tiempo
primero como ministro del área desde
junio del 2002 Y luego como presidente
de pedevesa desde noviembre del 2004 se
hizo cargo de ambas responsabilidades
hasta 2014 Poco después del
fallecimiento de Hugo Chávez
el ministro Rafael Ramírez que lo ha
nombrado ahora y estoy obligado a salir
en su defensa es un venezolano a carta
cabal un hombre honesto un trabajador
incansable tiene 10 años al frente del
ministerio ha hecho infinidad de ha
cumplido infinidad de tareas con una
gran eficiencia al frente de una tarea
nada fácil eh enfrentando conspiraciones
sabotajes etcétera Nosotros siempre
hemos creído lo hemos dicho públicamente
Rafael Ramírez ha sido uno bueno los
baluartes de esta Revolución Leal al
comandante Chávez
ahora bien Si todos los ministros del
chavismo iban y venían Por qué no
ocurrió lo mismo con el responsable del
sector petrolero Pues básicamente porque
revolucionario o no el dinero es lo
primero
Y es que fijaos de acuerdo con cálculos
del economista venezolano Francisco
monaldi profesor investigador del
instituto Baker de políticas públicas de
la universidad rice en Houston a partir
de los datos sobre la balanza de pagos
reportados por el Banco Central de
Venezuela durante el periodo
2004-2014 el país caribeño facturó en
dicho periodo de tiempo un millón de
millones de dólares esto es un billón de
dólares hispanos una cifra exorbitante
difícil de dimensionar digamos por poner
un ejemplo que con todo este dinero se
podría pagar la deuda Argentina con el
fmi unas 22 veces de locos hablamos por
tanto de una inmensa fortuna que fue
utilizada por no decir dilapirada por el
chavismo entre otras cosas para
financiar todo su plan de
nacionalización de las Industrias
básicas durante esos años el gobierno
venezolano compró por la fuerza decenas
y decenas de plantas y entidades
productivas priva así como bancos o
cadenas de supermercados en fin de todo
por supuesto estos ingentes fondos
fueron también claves para desarrollar
las grotescas redes de clientelismo que
el chavismo puso en marcha a fin de
asegurarse un amplio respaldo electoral
con fondos públicos queréis una prueba
Pues prestad
en el mercado capitalista está un
aproximado de 1899 bolívares fuertes
en la revolución en el socialismo está
en 1123
no te digo Aquí vamos a borrar
súper Chávez
857 va a costar esto
857 bolívares
es un ahorro de
55% menos de la mitad de precio
naturalmente todas las mieles de la
revolución dependían de una sola cosa
que debes a funcionará y logrará
facturar todo el dinero que el proyecto
chavista necesitaba no se podía jugar
con fuego la estabilidad aquí era clave
no sea que el flujo de dinero se
interrumpiera y por eso no hubo
prácticamente cambios Claro que eso con
Nicolás Maduro ha cambiado y mucho
la caída del muro de contención
en marzo del año 2013 días después del
fallecimiento de Hugo Chávez diosdado
cabello lanzó un mensaje particularmente
inquietante porque Chávez era el muro de
contención de muchas ideas locas esas
que se nos ocurren a nosotros de muchas
ideas locas que se nos ocurren a
nosotros
y el presidente imponía su liderazgo su
prudencia y su conciencia y nos evitaba
actuar en muchas ocasiones es decir que
aunque pueda sorprendernos Ahora resulta
que Chávez era el moderado pues vaya
moderado El caso es que si leemos entre
líneas y analizamos los sucesos
posteriores a la muerte del líder
chavista podemos ver que este tipo de
mensajes desafiantes no se dirigen hacia
la disidencia o la oposición política
sino sobre todo hacia el mismo chavismo
un movimiento que experimentó una
especie de balcanización una vez que
desapareció ese muro de contención
en abril del 2013 cuando Nicolás Maduro
ganó los comicios posteriores a la
muerte de Chávez por supuesto con
múltiples irregularidades de todo tipo y
chavismo se fragmento en varias
facciones una liderada por el propio
Nicolás Maduro la cual suponía de alguna
manera la continuidad ideológica de Hugo
Chávez otra capitaneada por Jorge arraza
entonces canciller que representaba a la
familia del propio bochave una liderada
por diosdado cabello a quien se señala
como un radical dentro del chavismo
crítico de la supuesta moderación de
maduro con ciertos temas y finalmente
otra vinculada con las fuerzas armadas y
pilotada por altos cargos uniformados
que estaban también al frente de
industrias básicas
naturalmente había otros muchos
caudillos de Rango medio que poco a poco
fueron integrándose en las diferentes
facciones y provocando muchos cambios
por ejemplo la familia de Hugo Chávez
fue perdiendo poder influencia mientras
que en paralelo Jorge y de Alci
Rodríguez hoy presidente del parlamento
y vicepresidenta respectivamente fueron
tomando fuerza
[Música]
en cierta forma solo las fuerzas armadas
y Nicolás Maduro lograron fortalecer su
posición Y a medida que este último
ganaba terreno iba expulsando a sus
propios disidentes dentro de la
Revolución Esto ocurrió incluso con los
pesos pesados fijaos 12 de diciembre de
2017 la fiscalía venezolana Investiga
Rafael Ramírez por corrupción en
pedevesa el ex ministro de energía y
petróleo predilecto del gobierno de Hugo
Chávez es indagado por su posible
responsabilidad en operaciones de
intermediación en la compra y venta de
crudo 13 de marzo de 2018 Miguel
Rodríguez Torres el exministro del
interior de Venezuela arrestado por
conjuras y complots contra el ejército
funcionarios del servicio bolivariano de
inteligencia nacional el sebin
detuvieron el martes en Caracas al
exministro del interior Miguel Rodríguez
Torres 25 de noviembre de 2021 ex fiscal
general de Venezuela Luis Ortega pide
asilo en España la ex fiscal general
Luis Ortega Díaz criticada del régimen
venezolano destituida en 2017 y
refugiada en Colombia pidió asilo
político en España ya lo veis purgas en
toda regla de antiguos líderes y
colaboradores del gobierno chavista que
de repente en un momento u otro dejaron
de encajar en la visión de Nicolás
maduro y como ocurre en todas las
dictaduras eso equivale a la persecución
política y policial al final diosdado
cabello se terminó alineando con Nicolás
maduro y el régimen venezolano quedó
compuesto por una especie de matriz
Bipolar interna donde civiles como
maduro cabello o Los Rodríguez por un
lado y los militares por otro acordaron
sostener conjuntamente el poder es decir
la balcanización que se produce tras la
desaparición de Chávez terminó
provocando la reconfiguración del
movimiento socialista y no el
desmoronamiento del régimen había que
salvar los privilegios a toda Costa pero
volvamos al punto clave Qué ocurrió en
todo este tiempo con pedevesa qué ha
pasado para que en marzo de 2023 se les
hace una nueva purga del chavismo a gran
escala Pues bien veamoslo
[Música]
el fin de la Venezuela Saudita
a pesar de que no es una frase
verificada se dice que John de
rockefeller pensaba que el mejor negocio
del mundo era una empresa petrolera y
que el segundo mejor era una petrolera
mal administrada con todo y eso la
pésima administración de pedevesa ha
provocado la histórica debacle de la que
fuera una de las economías petroleras
más sólidas del mundo un país que ahora
está a la cola de producción y riqueza
en el ranking de la OPEP el desastre ha
sido tan grande que si allá por los años
2012 y 2013 el país exportaba crudo por
unos 100 mil millones de dólares anuales
y el gobierno recibía más de 60.000 hoy
los números son tan pobres como estos
fijaos y Comparado 18 de noviembre de
2022 los ingresos petroleros de
Venezuela rondan los 3.500 millones de
dólares según maduro la producción
petrolera que llegó a ser de 3,2
millones de barriles diarios en 2002 se
desplomó a niveles históricos en 2020
cuando tocó su punto más bajo en décadas
mil barriles día un retroceso a niveles
de 1934 actualmente la producción ronda
los 700.000 barriles por día terrible la
gallina de los huevos de oro desapareció
por completo y es que a pesar de que los
rendimientos de pedevesa estaban en
Franco retroceso desde el año 2010 El
golpe de Gracia vino en 2019 con las
sanciones impuestas por Estados Unidos
desde entonces el régimen bolivariano
para asaltarse las sanciones tiene que
triangular la venta de crudo con un
sinfín de idas y vueltas que por
supuesto terminan siendo de todo menos
transparentes y es allí donde justo
estalló la purga chavista prestad mucha
atención
socialista
desde al menos cinco años El crudo
venezolano ha tenido que comercializarse
mediante intermediarios chinos indios y
rusos Generalmente usando criptomonedas
que permitan esconder el cobro de los
ingresos es por eso que las
investigaciones de la fiscalía chavista
se iniciaron en torno a la
superintendencia de criptoactivos y la
vicepresidencia de comercio y
suministros de pedevesa con este
circuito se ha detectado la pérdida de
cerca de 3000 millones de dólares
americanos según el fiscal chavista
tarek Williams Igualmente Quiero
recordar que una vez comercializado El
crudo asignado legalmente se incumplió
con los pagos correspondientes a
petróleo de Venezuela ahí Entonces dónde
está el daño patrimonial se determinó
que esta red utilizó un conglomerado de
sociedades mercantiles para legitimar el
capital
obtenido de dichas ventas por medio de
adquisición de criptoactivos
bienes muebles e inmuebles
inversiones En el sector de la
construcción inmobiliario demostrando
además un estilo de vida que no
corresponde obviamente a ningún
funcionario público es decir el sistema
fraudulento habría funcionado mediante
el cobro en criptomonedas del crudo
exportado cuya facturación luego no
llegaba a las arcas de pedevesa sino que
terminaban en otras cuentas paralelas
manejadas por funcionarios
en el marco de este proceso Perdieron su
puesto entre otros haré que laissami
quien era ministro de petróleo desde
abril de 2020 y había ocupado los cargos
de vicepresidente de Nicolás maduro
entre 2017 y 2018 y el Ministerio de
interior y Justicia de Hugo Chávez entre
el 2008 y el 2012 y por otro lado asdel
Chávez el presidente de pedevesa y primo
del fallecido presidente Hugo Chávez es
decir que hablamos de dos pesos pesados
sobre todo el del primero todo un capo
del régimen acusado de ser un importante
narcotraficante por Estados Unidos poca
broma ahora bien quiere decir esto que
el chavismo está ahora entrando en una
nueva era de transparencia y
responsabilidad institucional pues
lógicamente no Venezuela Es según el
Atlas de impunidad elaborado por eurasia
Group y el Chicago congloba la firms uno
de los 11 países con más impunidad del
mundo Venezuela está a la par de países
como Afganistán yemen Sudán burundi Chad
o Congo entre otros y siento decirlo
pero eso no parece que vaya a cambiar no
nos engañemos toda esta trama toda esta
enorme purga responde a sólo un objetivo
los intereses del señor Nicolás Maduro
Pero por qué ahora a quién le convenía
que todo este globo de corrupción
estallera justo ahora porque cargarse a
un peso pesado como tarea que laisami
pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
cerrando filas en torno a la tentativa
transición
según la Constitución Venezolana en 2024
tienen que celebrarse elecciones
presidenciales pero como todos sabéis
los comicios de este país están más
amañados que una partida de póker en
casa de Kim Jong y además el gobierno
acostumbra cuando se acerca el
calendario electoral ha inhabilitar a
los perfiles opositores que sean
relativamente competitivos para no
correr ningún riesgo inesperado sin
embargo 2024 llega con un contexto algo
diferente el desgaste económico chavista
es más que evidente pero el uso de la
fuerza facilita que se mantengan en el
poder pese a ello tanto la oposición
venezolana como Estados Unidos han
tratado de plantear la posibilidad de
una salida limpia el próximo año 29 de
noviembre de 2022 elecciones 2024 la
oposición venezolana buscará un acuerdo
electoral en la nueva fase de diálogo
con el chavismo la idea sería concurrir
a unos comicios transparentes donde
naturalmente el chavismo y que estos
entreguen el poder sobre la base de una
amnistía que apunte a una transición
democrática pacífica naturalmente que
queréis que os diga todo esto es más
idealista que probable Aunque en cierta
forma es una suculenta oferta para todos
aquellos que después de llenarse sus
bolsillos ahora quieran bajarse del
barco socialista abajo coste y Oye
disfrutar de los ahorrillos
tranquilamente sin embargo este
escenario es el que precisamente resulta
menos atractivo para las fuerzas armadas
del país
[Música]
tras el desplazamiento de aissami el
coronel Pedro tellechea fue elegido para
asumir el control de la cartera
petrolera con su ingreso al círculo rojo
la casa militar ya controla los
ministerios de defensa interior energía
eléctrica atención de las aguas
agricultura alimentación desarrollo
minero vivienda transporte Obras
Públicas Y es que hasta el despacho de
la presidencia y por encima de todas las
cosas tenemos la Joya de la corona la
gestión petrolera en un momento en el
que Estados Unidos parece dispuesto a
aliviar ciertas tensiones para que pueda
repuntar la producción petrolera en
estas circunstancias mejor un militar y
un supuesto narcotraficante para
contentar a Washington no os parece
Aunque a ver no implica que el primero
no sea lo segundo Pero bueno ya sabéis
la apariencia cuenta sea como sea de
esta forma las únicas ramas civiles que
permanecen consolidadas son las
vinculadas al propio Nicolás maduro y
los hermanos Jorge y delfi Rodríguez
como os decíamos antes presidente del
legislativo y vicepresidenta del país
respectivamente
los uniformados garantizan la
continuidad del régimen ellos son quizás
los más interesados en que este no caiga
el poder y los privilegios con los que
viven dentro del país no son comparables
con un retiro de la actividad aunque
esté lleno de garantías de impunidad y
amnistías que luego Habría que ver si se
cumplen o no digamos que los militares
han conformado algo así como una larga
más impenetrable y segura de decenas y
decenas de personajes que disfrutan de
un estatus Superior y que se sientan
legitimados por supuesto servicios a la
soberanía nacional un estatus que por
supuesto llegaría a su fin con cualquier
transición sí puede que algunos
disfrutarán de las amnistías prometidas
si es que luego se cumplen pero el
ejército forma una especie de piña mucho
más amplia por eso sistemáticamente
Nicolás Maduro trata de desplazar a
chavistas que quieran salir de la cancha
por militares leales Aunque eso suponga
darles más y más poder a los uniformados
el chavismo puede haber por tanto
lanzado esta lucha anticorrupción para
aliviar sus fuerzas de cara al futuro
fraude de 2024 Aunque la oferta
opositora se prepare para presentar un
candidato único
en cualquier caso estamos ante la última
purga bolivariana Y asistiendo a lo que
parece ser la lenta pero firme
militarización del poder político en
Venezuela un país donde el verde oliva
avanza sobre cada vez más y más áreas y
espacios de poder cada día que pasa
maduro y el destino de Venezuela parecen
más entregados a las fuerzas castrenses
y ahí tipos como tarea que laissami ya
no tenían sitio más aún cuando su
permanencia en el gobierno suponía un
enorme desplante para Estados Unidos
lealtades en el régimen bolivariano
ninguna el cheque siempre va primero
pero chicos hasta aquí turno para ti
Cuáles crees que serán las consecuencias
de esta purga petrolera en Venezuela
déjanos tu respuesta abajo en los
comentarios y si este vídeo te ha
resultado interesante No olvides darle
al botón de like y suscribirte a
visualpolitik si es que aún no lo has
hecho un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]